well shonda rhimes creator of the hit
show like grey's anatomy and scandal is
getting
rave reviews for her highly anticipated
new netflix series bridgeton
it is inspired by a best-selling book
series
set in england's regency era the early
1800s it follows daphne bridgeton the
oldest daughter
of an influential family navigating high
society matchmaking
there is scandal of course when an
anonymous columnist reveals
upper-class secrets reggae jean-page
plays the duke of hastings a
sought-after bachelor
who vows never to get married
however is it possible for a lady to
offer anything but a smile
while seated beside a duke even one of
your reputations you are aware of my
reputation unaware of your friendship
with my eldest brother if that were not
enough i'm
also aware of the things are certain
writers recently written of you
presumptuously arrogant most definitely
you are a rake through and through and
tell me i'm wrong
who is to refrain from thinking about
whom again i assure you i'm anything but
interested in you good quite and i
anything be interested in you
[Laughter]
reggae john page good morning thank you
so much for joining us i see you
cracking up right there just looking at
that
that clip good morning oh yeah he thinks
the gentleman does protest too much a
little bit there
um it's good fun to kind of see us
sparring it's it's it's kind of it's the
best kind of happy memories that i've
got being able to watch that stuff back
we had loads of fun in that set
you say that this is not your
grandmother's period drama so how would
you describe bridgerton
um i would say it is in a way your
grandmother's paradromas the period
dramas that you know and love but just
kind of funnier faster
more glamorous uh certainly a little bit
sexier um but also
it's not like we invented it it's been
going on for a few hundred years so
there's nothing new there either it's
just a lot more fun and unashamed of its
joy
you also said this is sort of a regency
romance through a woman's eyes
uh talk about that the feminist lens how
so
um well i think traditionally that
period dramas are very feminist i mean
we're
we're talking the uh in the tradition of
jane austen the bronte sisters mary
shelley
at the time when they were writing these
things like pride and prejudice this was
women stepping to the forefront of
literature in a way that they hadn't
before so that was a feminist revolution
200 years later and four or five ways of
feminist feminism later
i think it's only right that we keep
bringing that uh perspective in and keep
these stories revolutionary
um and so i think it's a lot about that
about bringing the female gays about
having
empowered um female leads in the shows
and about re-looking at what's
attractive about the masculine leads
like the guy that i
that i play i think the story the
conversations we're having about what
masculinity is and what's attractive
about that come into this as well so
there's loads and loads of fun little
things just kind of seeped into your
usual
kind of fun christmas drama well reggae
along those lines esquire called you the
leading man for the next decade
what do you make of that
what that was too much of it i think my
head might explode if i tried to think
about that too long
i'm very glad that other people are
having that conversation i'm just happy
to turn up and try and be helpful where
i can
i heard you were also relieved by the
diversity of the cast can you talk about
that a little bit
um yeah i mean i think it's it's great
to include people in our storytelling in
the 21st century i think we have a very
long
and sad tradition of excluding people
from stories excluding people from
history literally painting people out
of historical pictures and documents and
so it's the very least we can do to
start painting people back in um i think
if we're gonna have a great big fun
cinderella fantasy for christmas uh that
the more people who can play that more
people who are invited to participate in
that and see themselves as glamorous and
worthy of love and status the better
and so that's all what we're doing which
feels great all right i'm on episode 5.
i love it so far i can't wait to keep
watching but i want to know a little bit
more about you
not because you know just want to know
you're 30 years old you're from zimbabwe
and this is sort of like
your time how does that feel to see your
name and this project up in lights we
saw that you tweeted out
your billboard in times square
um it's a rush it's really really
exciting but it's exciting mostly to see
people excited about something that i've
done to see people excited about a thing
that you've made and put out into the
world
um in terms of thinking about myself i
do my absolute best not to that's why i
spend so much time pretending to be
other people
but i'm very very glad that other people
are enjoying what we've put out into the
world
apparently that's my problem i don't
pretend to be other people
it makes life a little easier what's it
like working with
chandra so wonderfully formed you don't
need to
i don't know about that like working
with shonda yeah what's that
what is that wonderful it's again very
relieving i mean i've worked for shut
with chandra for a couple of years now i
was
a company man that worked on a show
called for the people um and i was very
very lucky that as we were announcing we
were finishing up on that
i got the call where they were just like
hey don't go anywhere too quick we're
working on this other thing
it's british we've been talking about
you for ages and suddenly you're
available
so we had a conversation we talked about
all the kind of big
open field we had to run into with a
very traditional genre and how we could
bring that shondaland
21st century perspective to it and do
lots of kind of new and exciting
things that no one expects and just kind
of have more fun
than we've had before in the genre so
it's it's great it feels like coming
home working john land
awesome well congratulations to all of
you on that project
reggae john page vlad wanted to ask a
question but me and jamie sort of took
over
that's all right i understand how that
goes in the middle of that i'm so sorry
man
thank you again bridgette premieres
friday christmas day
on netflix i really did not want it was
an amb conversation i just wanted to
send my way out